millie we just rehydrated the brisket um
we
left it on for about 10 or 15 minutes
which kind of surprised me but it's like
that's what's going to do it give it the
time invest in it and um now what are we
doing so we're going to take our
leftover macaroni and cheese i mean
oftentimes there's never any leftover
macaroni and cheese but in this instance
we have a little bit left over so what
we'll do is we have some sliced pieces
they're already cold and we're gonna put
some into our waffle iron oh so you like
you chill it you chill it so this is
like when you have it left over you take
it out the um the casseroles is oh god
so we're gonna add one piece of macaroni
on the bottom only one's fitting in here
so then we're gonna put some cheese in
the middle oh okay more cheese sure
and then we'll take another piece of the
waffle and i mean the waffle the
macaroni and cheese we're going to put
it on top oh another okay great we're
going to create like a little sandwich
oh
i mean yes be careful that's really hot
yeah and then as it melts down it'll
close some
more and this is what it looks like
oh my god gooey nice and cheesy and then
we have our brisket
so we're just going to put some on top
look at this i'm going to put some on
top and you put as little as much as you
like on top
then i have some scallions i love a good
green onion i love a chive a scallion a
shallot an onion a garlic
everything yeah
i just made this like leek based soup
the other day and it was ugh it was so
good
i love all types of onions i
i'm going big here really and i can see
the onions which i really like there and
you saw how we caramelized them so they
got a little sweeter so this is like a
good balanced dish and then here i have
it with some another repurposed dish
this is my new york times mango slaw
and you can use leftover fruit that you
have in your refrigerator i have some
cabbage some carrots in there if you
have some collard greens that are left
over shred them up put them in there
this is a wonderful counterbalance to
all of this
savory cheesy
gooey deliciousness we have going on
well let's just taste this how about
that
just
you know okay now i'm focused on getting
the plate so clean you got to eat it
don't make it cold i might start licking
it i don't know
all right now
it's
gorgeous
okay here it is here's my
my plate that i worked so hard on
gorgeous
um
and now i'm gonna rip into it
this is good oh millie
i love that i asked you for a second
date i literally was like hi nice to
meet you can we do this again
look at how good that is
that little hit of the green the parsley
and the onion it really gives it that
brightness and that kick
of freshness come on chef juicy you see
our freshness brightness all of the chef
terms i love it look you use a savoring
all the moment right now because it's so
delicious you just want to get into it i
am a cookbook club um person i collect
cookbooks so i wanted to start a club
and also
i've learned to cook through watching
shows
and so these shows are very meaningful
and important they're educating all of
us right um and turning us in
to
more active chefs at home rather than
being insecure because you don't have
formal training or any training and you
don't need any and that's the beauty of
it like i'm not formally trained
these are just recipes that i've
cultivated these are recipes that i've
made my own and that's what i hope that
chef sky the soul food and all the
wonderful workshops on the magnolia
network teaches each and every person
whether it's you know hilton carter with
the plants and you know wonderful bakers
like elise smith and sam i'm going to
become a propagator because joanna you
know
hey bo has turned me on to the world of
propagating plants
i mean i get so much i yesterday i was
drooling over her fettucine alfredo like
i'm a magnolia girl through and through
and they are better off for having you
oh thank you on their network and we
want to thank them for all these
wonderful opportunities
thank you
milly pearce go to the
dreamheartshow.com for the full recipe
and watch millie's magnolia workshop
series a chef's guide to soul food
exclusively on the one and only magnolia
[Music]